bonjour je travaillais comme ingénieur
jusqu'en 2008 et j'ai été cadre saq
kilos vous voulez parler des chiens la
place comment se déroule votre
convalescence monsieur ce n'est pas ce
qu'elle n'aurait pas survécu et le sud
de 90 mètres pour finir comblé ici la
question des dommages intérêts ça peut
être important
ma femme c'est une société anonyme
corporate et d'un chip univers à haut
potentiel les garçons c'est
l'opportunité d'intégrer l'univers à
haut potentiel des meilleures
universités américaines
excusez moi faty de monsieur ça y est
vous avez besoin de vivre une expérience
positive
q vous avez déjà ramassé les déjections
canines être avec full les relations
soient dans le symbole
oui tu t'entends il va rien il revend 80
elle promène des chiens pour vraiment me
suis en chute libre
en fait je crois que je veux rien ni
procès ni accord négocié
je me présente mon mari il est gentil
quand c'est un chien de combat lors du
moment qui vous confond pas avec un
autre chien mehmedi à ce point de break
avec de travail ses docteurs la ville
je crois que ce serait bien que tu
acceptes de discuter un peu avec lui
ceux qui vous aiment ça y est pour
beaucoup
vraiment vraiment canon est le foot est
par définition que ça vient toujours
sous la forme de l'ina d'un dieu